went out on our top story and the
Russian oil price cap joining us is
still Evita Chauvin who's an energy
analyst he is live from Riyadh thank you
very much Sarah for being with us on Al
Jazeera so this prize cap is meant to
put more pressure on Moscow over its
invasion of Ukraine what impact is it
likely to have for us on Russia's income
its economy in the short term and long
term
um
I think the
effect will be not extremely high
because
um
Russian
orals are being traded at 50 dollars per
barrel so it's very below
um the EU
issue um so um in in a reality Uh
Russian oil will be
uh trading as a normal and you even
could argue
um the EU
approach or the cheese they haven't
approached even
opens more
avenues for Russia to take oil because
as long as you are trading below this 60
dollar Mark you are able to trade in a
Russian oil and what are the possible
unintended consequences of all of this
the knock-on effect on the global energy
sector
um the main effect that I see is that
um a that
Russian oil will go into Asia even more
um and that
um the EU
ng7 will be uh paying a higher price
because
the rational that was even still going
into the EU will be going outside now
and we are we
EU will be facing a higher oil
prices well at the same time
um what the market knows but EU maybe
not
um Russian oil will go to Asia will end
up in a refineries and uh China India
maybe even Egypt is Saudi or turkey and
most probably will end up as Chinese
Indian or Egyptian oil products in the
EU so for Russia the main effect at
present is
zero
maybe in in the long term
um there will be encased pressure F
prices worldwide will go up okay thank
you so much for talking to us about this
thank you for your Insight zero
verashovan an energy analyst joining us
there from Riyadh we appreciate your
time thank you